[MUSIC PLAYING]
- But happy
Thursday, everybody.
Welcome back to the
Data Science Hangout this week.
If it's your first
time joining us today,
it's so nice to meet you.
Thank you all for spending
your Thursday with us.
If we haven't met, I'm
Rachael Dempsey. I lead
customer marketing at Posit and I'm
the host of the Data Science Hangout.
This is our open space
to chat about data science leadership,
questions you're facing,
and getting to hear about
what's going on in the world of
data across
different industries.
And so we're here every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
I'll say except the
week of September 18th,
we will be at
the Posit conference in Chicago.
And I'm excited to meet so
many of you there in person.
So let us in the chat if
you're going to be there.
The conference will also have
a virtual experience as well.
Let me just--
I'll share this in the
chat as well if you
want to check it out.
But anyways,
if you are watching
this recording on YouTube later
sometime in the future,
the link to add the live events
to your calendar will be in the
details below on
YouTube as well.
But at the Data
Science Hangout,
we are all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment
for everyone.
We love to hear from everyone,
no matter your years of
experience, titles, industry,
or the languages
that you work in.
And every week,
I'm joined by a different
leader from the community who
joins us to share their experience
and answer questions from you all.
It's totally OK if you just
want to listen in here.
Maybe you are doing some other
work in the background as well.
But if you want to ask
questions or provide your own
perspective, you can jump in
by raising your hand on Zoom.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat.
And always feel free to put a
little star next to it if it's
something you want me to ask instead of
me calling on you to ask it live.
And then we also have a
Slido link which I see Curtis just
shared in the chat where
you can ask questions anonymously too.
But with all that,
thank you again,
for joining us
here this Thursday.
I am so excited to be
joined by my co-host,
Gabriela de Queiroz, principal
cloud advocate at Microsoft.
And I was just talking
with Isabella on our team,
you've been like a
dream co-host of mine, Gabriela.
So I'm so excited
to have you here.
I'd love to have you introduce
yourself and maybe share a
little bit about your role and
also something you like to do
outside of work too.
- I'm so happy to be here.
I miss this community so
much and the interaction,
and I'm sad that I will
not be at the conference.
So yeah, so
Gabriela de Queiroz.
I've been with Microsoft
for a little bit less than
a year. I just actually moved
teams, it's going to
be official September 1st.
But my work now, it's
going to be towards
startups.
So I'll be working on startups,
helping them leveraging
the power of Microsoft Cloud
and the products that we have.
Also help them navigate
this whole landscape.
Making sure that
they have a lot of questions around
should I buy or should I build.
So we are going to be advising
the mostly AI startups
to see where they can
leverage AI successfully,
sharing our
knowledge and so on.
But
before that, I worked for IBM
and other small companies.
Always doing like,
data science,
some advocacy. Sometimes I was
as an advocate, as a role
I had like right now,
I had advocacy in my
title but I was always an
advocate in any role
that I was performing.
And I also founded
two communities. One, it's R-Ladies,
which I'm pretty sure almost
everybody here should know or
have heard about,
which I'm so grateful
for the community.
The other one is AI Inclusive.
And
what I like to do when
I'm on my free time,
so I love water. So if I can
be in the water, in the pool or
in the ocean,
anything
related to water,
it's my happy place.
So I'm back to
doing some kind of
going with my kids to
the pool and enjoying summertime.
- That's great. Well, thank
you so much, Gabriela.
And thank you for the
introduction to your role as
well. I know you mentioned AI
Inclusive a bit and R-Ladies.
And many of us
might be familiar with R-Ladies,
not as familiar
with AI Inclusive.
But would you be able to
just kind of describe what both of
those communities are?
- Yeah, so R-Ladies,
it's been almost 11 years
since I founded R-Ladies
here in San Francisco. And
the goal is to bring more
diversity into the R community.
It all started here in San Francisco
but we have chapters, what we call
all over the world.
I think we have over 200
chapters in more than 60-plus countries
with
thousands and
thousands of members.
And in each chapter they
organize and the way that works
best for them, it could be
like, they do workshops or they do
book clubs together or
they go through
lectures together.
But the main thing is about
creating this community.
And you can see one thing
that I always mention is it's hard
to say about numbers,
how R-Ladies changing the ecosystem.
The best way is to see
the pictures from the
conferences, how it was before
and how it is right now in
terms of diversity.
And then AI Inclusive,
it was another organization
that I created in 2018
when I was very much involved
in this AI discussion
about discrimination,
bias, and so on. And one of
the things that I noticed when we
were discussing those things is that
it was very US Silicon Valley centric,
all the discussions, and
the rest of the world,
they were not aware of
the implications of AI.
And they were the ones--
like in some particular places,
they were the ones that were
going to suffer the most.
So
my idea with the community
was kind of like twofold.
The first one was to bring
awareness of the implications
of AI, and the second
one was to empower
the underrepresented
community to
learn about the AI and
to have the tools to
make decisions and to be
knowledgeable about things that
are happening and also
entered the workforce.
- Absolutely. Thank
you for sharing those.
I was going to put in the chat
if anybody wants to be the
first to share the links
to those two organizations in the
chat, that would
be helpful too.
People are really
quick on that.
But Gabriela,
something I really wanted to
ask you about and something we
spoke about a bit before
is the power in
building relationships within an
organization.
And you shared with me how
you moved from a company
where everybody knew you to
having to then prove yourself
again in a new role.
And I was wondering if you'd be
able to just share a little bit
about that experience with us.
- Yeah, absolutely. So
I left IBM, which is
a huge company. So
300,000 employees.
But I was there for a little
bit over four years and I knew
a bunch of people.
Because one of
the things that I did with
my role was to connect with
different teams and working
with different teams.
So I knew a bunch of people.
And then when I moved to Microsoft,
even on my team, they didn't know
about my past, the things
that I've done in the past.
And not a lot of people inside
Microsoft knows who I am.
So it's like, you need to
create your reputation,
your brand again
from scratch where you
have to prove yourself,
you have to show others your value.
And
I think it's so difficult in that way.
I thought it would be easier
but it's so hard because also
like, you don't
know the channels.
Which channels
should reach out.
We use different tools, so you
have to get used to the tools.
You need to find your
communities inside the company,
and it's not very
straightforward how to find
those communities.
You need to build relationships again,
so it takes time. And I didn't--
I had no idea.
Maybe also
another reason could be because
everybody or most of us are
remote, so we don't interface
with each other. So like,
there is no whole conversation or
seeing each other in the office,
getting to know their faces. So
it's been hard. It's
been hard. It's like,
it's one step after the other.
It's trying to even give talks
internally, seeing how I
can participate in other projects,
connect to people
one on one and so on.
- I see
Luke put in the chat,
every career changer is nodding along
to the story. So do you have
any specific tips for people
of what you've experienced
in moving into Microsoft?
- It's making sure that
you set time to go and
find people and schedule
one-on-ones. And then you ask
that person, oh, is there
anyone that I should meet?
And then it's
going this cascades
motion. It's like, OK, I should
meet this other person. OK, oh,
there's this other
thing I should meet.
Oh, there is this group. Oh,
I should go and
talk to this group.
Oh, there is this other group
and so on.
So that would be my advice,
a lot of one-on-ones and doing
a lot of search inside the
tools that you have. Yeah,
it's snowball sampling,
it's snowball effect.
That's pretty much
what I did, what
I've been doing.
And it's been almost
a year and I feel like
I still have a long way to go.
- Thank you. That's really
helpful. I see Dipsha,
you had asked a question.
I think it was actually over
on Slido but I saw your name
there. So do you want
to ask that live?
- Hi, Gabriela. Always fun to hear
you talk about your work and your path.
One thing that I've always
admired about you is your
ability to constantly learn.
But especially as an advocate,
how do you keep up with
the field that is growing faster
than our speed to
keep up with it?
Any advice for--
- It is so hard because
it's faster than ever. It's
like, before the whole AI,
the generative AI and all
the tools and everything that it's
being born these days,
it was hard to keep
up, right? Now, it's
I get very overwhelmed with
like, oh, should I know this?
Should I know that? Oh,
now there is this new tool.
So I try to focus as much
as I can and not being very
stressed about all
the new things,
because there is a
lot of noise as well.
And making sure that I have
a network of people that I can
leverage them and their knowledge
so I can get my
knowledge as well instead of
me trying to figure out myself.
So that has been
my tip or
my suggestion
for myself because I used
to get very stressed. I'm like,
I'm so behind. I mean,
this catch up mode all the
time and there is no ends.
And I don't think I will
survive if I keep doing this.
So let me be a little bit
more smart and strategically.
So I leverage my
peers, my co-workers.
Even you, Dipsha, we have some
calls every now and then to share
the things that she's doing with
R which I'm not doing as
much. And I'm like,
I want to know what is
happening in the world of R.
And so we have some
conversations. So it's
leveraging people
is the best way that I found to
be up to date on what is happening.
- I like to remind everybody
because I forget to say this
again. If you join after
the initial introductions,
there's a few different
ways you can ask questions.
So I see people have figured
out you can write in the chat
here on Zoom. But if you
also wanted to jump in live,
you can raise your hand on Zoom
or use the Slido link to ask
anonymously, which Curtis
will share again in a second.
But
S. Moorthy,
S. Moorthy, I see you had
asked a question here in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
S. MOORTHY: Sure.
Sorry, my camera's not working.
- No worries.
S. MOORTHY: So
i am a pure biologist by
trade but I've really started
enjoying data science and really
see my future in that field.
And I always wonder,
because now both Microsoft, Amazon,
Google are all jumping
on the genomics boat and
would entertain one of these
companies be a potential
a job for me.
So in your experience,
how do you deal with or
manage people who come from really
different backgrounds that
might not be traditionally
computational or traditionally
statistics or math?
And how do you actually
leverage their knowledge in
your work environment?
- Yeah, that's a great
question. And when I'm hiring,
I'm looking for
a broad
set of skills. Like,
I try to make it--
I say that it's kind
of like a puzzle.
It's like bringing
together a team,
it's like building
this puzzle where
I need people with
different backgrounds,
different set of skills,
different set of ideas,
different ways of
working and thinking.
And I feel like the academic,
if you have an academic
background, no matter which one,
it's also very helpful and you
bring a lot of expertise and
deep knowledge that maybe other
professionals don't have as
much or vice versa.
One thing that I think--
and you don't have to
have the traditional like statistical
background or computer science.
It's well proven that doesn't,
what do you say?
The best teams are
the most diverse ones.
And I do believe that a lot.
And I've been building several teams
for the past few years, and
I saw
through my teams. And
so there are a lot
of opportunities.
And the other thing that I
think about is like, if there
is an area that
you are an expert,
that you feel like
try to find a job
that you can relate.
And
I'll give an example.
So I was in academia for
several years before moving to
the industry. And
it was hard for me
to make the bridge between the
academic world and the industry world.
So once I was talking to
people to try to understand,
one of the things
that I realized is
we all have the same--
kind of a similar knowledge but
the name, the way that we name
things, the terminology,
they are so different but
they mean the same thing.
Once I was able to have that
clicked, I was like, OK,
so you are talking
about this. Oh yeah,
I know what this thing is.
Oh, this thing is this, this,
and this that I learned when
I was doing my research.
Oh, the model that you're
using in the industry is called
this other thing. Oh,
yeah, I know what it means.
So once I was able to
make this connection,
it became much easier.
- What's the biggest
thing that happens with
where I mean,
we call them two totally different
things but they mean the same things.
- Say it again.
- Where do you see
that happening the Most
- Oh,
even statistics and
machine learning, for example,
that was the first
insight. Like, oh yeah. Or
if you go to a certain
industry like advertisement,
they have a lot of acronyms,
they love acronyms.
And then you have to understand
what the acronyms mean.
And then you're like, OK,
I know what it is.
- Yeah, definitely. Libby,
I see you had a question
here in the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
- Sure.
I was wondering because
you mentioned buy versus build
questions for the startups
that you work with.
I was wondering if there
are any other problems that you
could kind of describe
that these startup companies are
facing in this landscape and kind
of how your team helps. Like,
is it a lot of
research where you're researching things and
then bringing knowledge back
to your clients or is it
relationship building with
experts and then bringing those
experts in to talk to the
clients? What does that look like?
- Yeah, so let me talk about
the first one. There is a lot
of noise right now
in the AI space.
A lot of startups being
created every day.
One of the things that I see
happening
very often is like, they haven't done
the kind of research
side of knowing that,
is there any other company that
is doing the same thing that
I'm trying to build?
So there is like,
the same thing being built over
and over and over again with
just a different kind of look and feel.
And
so there is this market
research that they haven't
done, so I would
call it the homework.
Making sure that
what you are doing,
there is a value behind
and that you have a value
proposition. So I usually
go to some events and I
say, oh, "Give me your pitch.
Tell me about your company."
And they were like, "O yeah,
we have this wrapper
around the OpenAI,
API,
and you get a model."
And I'm like, "OK, but what
is the new thing here?"
"Oh, not much." And I'm
like, "OK, who are your customers?
Who are you targeting?" "Oh,
I haven't thought about this." So
there is a lot of
things that I feel like
it's missing on the startup.
And the startups that I'm
talking to, they are in the
very, very, very,
very early stages.
Usually,
they don't have any
funding,
they are not backed
by any VC or anyone,
they are just starting.
It could be like a one-person
startup or it can be like a
five people startup.
It can be an idea as well
and they are thinking of like
incorporating or becoming a startup.
So that's the first challenge.
The other question that
you mentioned about the knowledge.
So yes, we do--
not like research in the way
that we do is like knowing what
is happening in this space
and also like understanding,
what is the value that
we bring as Microsoft?
How we compare with other
companies as well. And we know
that those startups.
And as they progress
or even in the beginning,
they are not going to
be building in one cloud.
They are not going to be
building on only Microsoft,
they are probably going to be
building in this what we call multicloud
environment. So they are going
to be using Microsoft Cloud, AWS,
Google Cloud platform.
And how can we incorporate
the other clouds,
make sure that they
have a good workflow?
So
we also research what the other
companies are doing but also like,
what are the advantages that
we are offering to our startup
ecosystem?
And there is a team.
It's not only my team but there
is several and different teams working with
the Microsoft Word
startup teams.
- How do you find like, these
early stage
startups to talk to?
I guess I'm thinking as
you were telling that story like,
if I was a startup,
I would probably need to feel like
this might just be how I am,
like too prepared for that
conversation before I'm talking
to Microsoft. Like, how do
you first get connected with them?
- So
a few ways. One is we're
going to events and talking to
them. And it could be a
one-on-one or us being on a
stage or us having a booth.
But also, we have a platform.
So we have something
called Founders Hub,
which is a platform
that any startup,
anyone with an idea
can come and sign up.
And there is a lot of benefits
that you can get. Like,
you get OpenAI credits, Azure,
which is the Microsoft Cloud
credits, you get access to
one-on-one conversation
with experts,
you have technical
advisors and so on.
So I see these two
ways, like one is through
events and us connecting with
them, and the other one
is through our platform,
which they should be aware
in some ways maybe it was a
campaign that we did, maybe they
knew about the platform because we
were in an event so it's a
lot of awareness.
These are the two kind
of ways that we see,
we interact with startups.
- OK.
So people go from they have
an idea and then they get into
this program to make it a
more official startup as well.
- Yeah.
And it's not even a program,
it's a platform. It's a platform.
It's kind of like a self-serve
platform where you can
redeem a lot of credits
and benefits.
- Thank you. Eugene, I see
you had a question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in here?
EUGENE: Sure. This
might be controversial
mostly in the sense that
OpenAI and Microsoft
are now partners,
very tight. And
there's a sense that
at least from my perspective,
if AI is kind of very,
very good at solving
software problems,
it feels like it's just a
matter of time before a good
product manager could ask
it to start tinkering,
put together a
ticketing system,
and now ServiceNow
is out of business.
So Whisper, for example,
just released a little bit
of extra voice controlled stuff that
is a step up in terms
of their authentic answering systems too. Now,
there's a company called
ElevenLabs and another one
called WellSaid that are
literally focusing on that
exact problem. So wouldn't
those companies immediately--
I mean given the computing
resources and AI is going to
win with more compute,
given the computing
resources of Microsoft
and OpenAI, as a startup,
I am curious and
scared in a sense.
I'm actually in
the bioinformatics field,
so I know you guys have
a good partnership with
Epic, and they're
doing incredible stuff.
Like have tons of ideas
and Epic's doing it all.
But
why ever come up with a new--
if AIs can do all these things,
I'm scared as a startup to talk to
you because if I start using your resources,
you might figure out how my code
works and then well crap, my startup is
not going to do too well.
I mean, it's a fearful thing.
So I'm just curious if you have
had this conversation or if
other people are
worried about this.
- Not exactly.
Well, and one of the things I
can speak about is when you are using
anything under
Microsoft, even we have
Azure OpenAI service
which is kind of like the
same APIs that OpenAI has,
but we have several
layers that differentiate ourselves from
for example OpenAI's
like security, SLA, privacy.
We also have
responsible AI guardrails
and your data don't
get stored. Like,
we don't use your data to
train or to do anything.
So there is a lot of things
we don't see what
you are doing.
But I see your point.
If you are starting
from scratch, you think like,
am I going to succeed because
there are these other big
companies doing similar
things? But I don't think so.
I think startups, they are
in a very specific niche
that other big
companies are not doing,
and they are not sometimes
interested in doing.
So that's where I see some gaps where
the AI startups
can come in and serve
that particular audience.
I'll give an example.
One
startup called Perplexity AI,
you could say, oh,
they are similar to
what OpenAI is doing,
maybe what Bing is doing.
But I would recommend for
you to check out to see how
different they are.
And
it's not the same
thing. And also like,
it's a different audience.
Anyway, so I don't see
that worry coming from startups.
They are very excited. It seems
that the whole tooling
around the AI became
a way of making them
powerful to build something.
Even people that had no coding
experience, now they can
go and build something.
I hope that kind of helps
answer your question.
But I can see that it's
a very complicated and
delicate discussion to have.
I'm happy to have
more discussion around this.
- Thank you.
John, I see you had a
question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in here?
And we have a few Johns,
so was John Harmon.
But I can ask the question and
if you want to jump in and add
context, feel free.
But the question was,
It used to be easier to keep
up with the R stats world before
say, October 27 2022. I'm
guessing this is related to Twitter.
Have you adjusted to the
changed social media landscape?
If so, what have you done?
- Not much. It's kind of hard
to keep up with the social media.
I was a
heavy user of Twitter and then
people migrate to one and then
migrate to the other one,
and then I lost track.
I don't know where
the community is anymore
so I'm like, OK,
I'm going to stay with LinkedIn
but I know that some people
is there.
But I haven't found my
home again. I'm still on Twitter
but I haven't found like,
a social media that works
where I feel like the community
that we used to have on Twitter.
- Any ideas, feel free
to share in the chat.
I've definitely been
heavy on the LinkedIn
but always on LinkedIn.
- Blue sky,
I haven't used it.
I have Macedon.
But
it took me a while to
understand, and I'm not--
I don't know, I don't feel
like I'm comfortable with the UI,
so I go always back to Twitter.
But then the community is not
there, then I go to LinkedIn.
So it's a mess. I
would say it's a mess.
I do miss our community in the
way that we use to share knowledge.
- A question I had wanted
to ask you about is
thinking about R-Ladies
and AI Inclusive,
how have you helped
those organizations grow?
It's amazing to see how
many different chapters of R-Ladies
there are across the
world, for example.
- One of the things
that helped us for sure
was coming from
being a one person
working on the organization to being
a team and to have money
so we had funding. So
that's where R-Ladies started to grow.
But I would say that not only
having a team and funding
is also making sure that you
are taking care of your community.
I remember for several years, I
would go to meetups and events,
and I would handle
a little card with not only
my name but the R-Ladies
website. And I would say, hey,
do you know about
this community? It's awesome.
And you should check it out.
So it was a word of mouth
by myself doing this type of thing.
But it really changed when
we had a team behind and the
funding, which came first
from the AI consortium.
- Thank you.
Allen, I see you had a
question here in the chat.
Want to jump in?
ALLEN: Yeah. Hi, Gabriela.
This is a great conversation,
thank you. I'm
curious if Microsoft
is doing anything
institutionally to promote
solutions for things like
algorithmic bias and AI issues
with training
data shaped by
biases and so on.
And I also wonder if working
in the startup space,
if there are
opportunities for you to
be the change that you want
to see in the world with respect
to inclusion in AI communities,
people doing AI but also in
the data, in the
foundational stuff.
Are there
opportunities for you?
Do you see levers that you
can pull in that space there?
- Yeah, absolutely.
And Microsoft has a
whole organization around this
particular theme
around responsible AI.
I don't know the name of
the organization, but
they have several--
not only like
well-known researchers
doing research
but people working with
customers to make sure that
they have this responsible AI principles
embedded into the system.
When we talk about startups,
we also emphasize the
responsibility that they have
and the way that they can
mitigate bias, that they can
be more knowledgeable about
this topic. And in the
product itself, we have it imbibed.
So startups,
some of them, they like, oh,
I don't want to know about this.
But it's our role as being
part of Microsoft, educate
them about this as well.
Even if they don't
want to hear or listen
about this but it's
in our responsibility to be
that person that's like oh
yeah, you have to listen to
this. It's important.
And sometimes they
don't know. Like,
they were not educated or
they didn't know about those problems
because they never had any issues.
But
it's part of our let's
say speech when we talk.
ALLEN: Great. Thanks.
I appreciate hearing that
that's sort of embedded in the
approach. I think that's
really important going forward.
Thank you.
- It is. And the whole company,
we had to go through several
trainings as well. And
there is a lot of
resources for us. And how to
learn, where to learn, how to
talk about it, what are some
resources that could
be helpful for you
and so on.
- I like the tip you
shared about the business cards with
the community. And I
was just thinking about,
a lot of us who
might be going to
conferences again where we
haven't been to them in a few
years, do you have other advice
or tips for people to get the
most out of conferences?
- And that was--
I just wrote in the
chat, that was before stickers because
I think stickers would
be easier to handle,
to hand and to give people.
But back then, we didn't have this
sticker
kind of like, fever
conferences.
Well, in my opinion, the
best thing at conferences is the
talk, like the whole
conversation. More than talks
is the conversation
and reconnecting with people.
So usually when I go to
conferences, I pick some talks
that I'm like oh,
I can't miss those.
This other one, OK,
maybe I can. But like,
the whole conversation, the
connections that I make,
every time I go to
conferences, it's priceless.
And that's why I go to
conferences. It's not about the talks,
it's about
the people.
- Let me just check here to
see if I missed questions in
the chat here.
I know there's a lot
of conversation happening about the
different social
networks and stuff here.
Let's see. But
if I missed one of your
questions there, feel free to recopy
and paste it so
we see it again.
But a question that I love
to ask our featured leaders here,
Gabriela, is is there a
piece of career advice
that comes to mind,
whether you've been the one to
give it or that you've received
that you think is
very impactful?
- I would say is the one about
applying for a job even if
you feel like you are not qualified,
because that's the starting
point. If you don't apply,
there is no way that
it can get that role.
So that would be the
first one, is apply,
apply as much as you can,
even if you feel like
you don't qualify.
So that would be my first one.
- That's a great one.
On the conference conversation,
I see somebody asked a Slido
question that was, do you have
any networking tips for
the socially anxious?
The thought of handing out
cards or stickers makes me
break out in a cold sweat.
- Let me share something
interesting. So I was not--
and I don't consider
myself being an extrovert
person.
I think if in a place
where I feel comfortable, then I can
be that person. But like, if I
go to a place, an event where I
don't know anyone, it's
so hard to break the ice.
But it's been an exercise
that I've been doing for
well, let's say
probably 20 years.
And because one of the things
that I wanted to change in myself
was to be that person
that would talk to others. And
it always started--
and I'm going back in time,
just to share that I
was very anxious about being surrounded
by people and being the
center of attention.
But for several years,
I worked with some music
bands and singers,
and I was doing the
production side.
So I would have to go and
hand flyers and go and talk to
the press about the
upcoming concerts.
And then I remember talking
to someone and I'm like,
this is so hard for me.
And then someone told me,
"Is there anyone
that you admire?
That is that person that you
would like to be in terms of
that specific skills?" And
I'm like, "Yes, there is."
So I would see that person
and I would try to see how
they behaved, how they interact,
and I would try to mimic
and my hands would be sweating.
And I would be like
not being able to talk very
much. And my ideas would all blank.
But anyway, all
that to say that
I don't think it's like
some of us are extroverts.
By the end of a conference
or mid day of a conference,
I go back to my room and
I'd be quiet because I can't talk to
people anymore. And then I recharge
and then I can go back.
But try maybe the
one-on-one. Like,
instead of talking
to a lot of people,
I prefer usually to do
one-on-ones than to have a
group of people. One,
because it's a lot of noise
and I can't project my voice in
that way to people to listen
to me. So I really like the
one-on-one in the corner, and I
feel like I take more out of
these one-on-ones than
a group conversation.
- Definitely.
I'll share something that has been
useful for me with that is
if I see that somebody
posted on LinkedIn or wherever that
they're going to be
at that conference,
I'll connect with them
and just say like, hey,
I saw you are also going
to this conference or like, hey,
looking forward to seeing
you at Posit's conference.
And it just makes me
feel more comfortable than saying hello
to them in person because
of already reached out to them
before. And in my mind I
have an idea of maybe 5 to 10
people who are going to seem
familiar to me that I could
then talk to. I don't
know if that's helpful for anybody.
I see Libby you had an
idea in the chat too.
Do you want to jump in?
- Yeah, so I'm a
big introvert who
talks to a lot of people
and has a podcast and does things
that are not
introvert-like at all.
And
I give myself a job. Like,
I volunteer for something.
Can I help you with something?
Can I sign up for something?
Something that gives me a
purpose and then I know what
I'm doing. I have
an objective, right?
And I also have
something in my hands,
I always bring my
camera. That way,
I have a reason to
talk to somebody,
they have a reason to talk to me,
I have a reason to walk away. Like, oh,
I got to go take a picture
of those people and then walk away.
Just gives me an
object that I can
use as a focal point.
And then my other piece
of advice is to practice. Like,
we all have this strange
assumption that we're supposed
to know how to talk to people.
No, not everyone does.
And we just went through
a pandemic where we weren't
getting as much FaceTime as
we normally maybe would have. So
figure out how to phrase things
and then practice them out loud
in the mirror or whatever
it takes. Give yourself
a little bit of help.
-
I love that idea of giving
yourself a job and just like
carrying your camera and
making your own job there.
I think that helped as
being like a community organizer too
for local meetup groups,
because you always did have something you
had to go run and do as well.
I see--
oh, there you go.
- No, that's a great tip.
And I have a huge--
I'm very self-conscious. And
no matter how many people told
me otherwise with
my English. Like, I've
been in the US for
11, 12 years, and I
still struggle with English. And
everybody says no, I
can understand you perfectly.
But every day, it's a
struggle. And I'm like, OK,
I'm going to fight this. I'm
going to get on the phone.
I'm going to make
this appointments.
I'm going to try to--
So
it's not natural.
Again,
it can be in other
forms as well,
especially if you don't
speak the language
or if you are very conscious
about the way that you speak
and you cannot express yourself the way
that you would like to, it can be
frustrating as well.
- Yeah,
absolutely.
Saptarishi. And apologies if
I mispronounce anybody's name.
I see you had asked a
question in the chat.
Do you to jump in here?
- Hi. You got my pronunciation
right, you're fine.
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah.
So I'm a marketing analytics
student here at Simon Business School,
but I've found myself really
interested in data science over
the past one year.
And I've been getting really more
and more into it more like practice.
And I've had a few
portfolio worthy projects but with the
kind of market situation and how
it is in the professional environment,
I'm really struggling and wondering how
I should like break into it.
And I always wonder if I'm
like good enough yet or not because
there's always
something new to learn.
There's always a new tool.
So I was wondering if there
is something that I could
particularly do that's
probably going to help me out.
- Yeah, there is
always something to learn. Like,
you can ask a few questions--
like, not a few,
several questions you may know and
I will say I don't know but
I can probably figure out.
It's impossible to
know everything.
So
my suggestion is always like,
if you come from marketing,
if you come from
biology, if you come from
epidemiology, try to find a job
where you can leverage those skills
so
you know the domain.
So you also know data
science but maybe
the person that is hiring
cannot see how much you know
because you don't
have experience,
work experience with data
science but you have knowledge
about marketing.
So we can try to
highlight
the pieces that you
know more and find
a job that is more
focused in that area.
And then you can
start from that place.
Another
suggestion would be
the first job is
the hardest for sure. The first
one is going to be the hardest.
I'm not saying that
the second, the third,
the fourth and the
fifth, it's easy.
I
got a lot of rejections
when I was applying to
every time I changed jobs.
It's like I get a
lot of rejection,
so I don't think it ever ends.
But I would say the
first one is the hardest.
Even if you have to do
two steps back and start
in a more like beginner
role, that's fine
because I see that
it's an investment.
So that would be my suggestion.
And apply. Apply, apply, apply, because
that's the way the
industry works is like,
you have to apply as much
as you can. And it's ridiculous,
you apply to 200, 300 jobs
sometimes and you get maybe 5,
10 interviews if you are lucky.
So keep applying,
and I'm sure you'll get
something very soon.
- Thank you.
And when you were talking about
that first job being the hardest,
it was just reminding me you're
talking about your job in music production.
And I would just love to hear
a little bit about your early
career journey or how
you got into data.
- Oh, that's a
long, long story.
So first of all,
that was back in Brazil.
So I didn't know exactly
what I want to do or
what major I wanted to do.
So I did a lot of back and
forth and trying other things
and not doing anything but
working with music because it
was something that I
was passionate about.
So there is a lot
of back and forth
in my career.
And I say that it's never
too late for you to apply
and work in a place that
you want to work for.
So I finished my bachelor.
I always say that
I was almost 30.
And I think in the past,
even my family, they were like oh,
I don't know what's going
to happen to Gabriela because
she's trying all these other
things and she's not finishing
school. Like, she's trying
these different majors
and stopping.
But then I found my way.
Then I found something that I really
fell in love, which was statistics.
But even then it took me
forever to finish my course.
So anyway, all that to say
that it's never too late.
All the experience that you have
done in the past is going
to be helpful in some
ways. Like, I think that
starting a community
and being an advocate,
those two things,
when I was working with music,
if I haven't worked with music,
I'm not sure if I was able
to do those two things because a
lot of skills that I developed
when I was doing the music
production helped me with these
two pieces and being able to
talk and communicate
because I had to do this.
So nothing that you do is
lose, like, don't loss.
I don't believe that it's like
there is this run that you have
to finish and you have to
start programming at the age of five
to be someone
successful by 30. Maybe,
sure, yeah but I
don't regret any loops
that I did.
-
I absolutely love hearing
about those lessons learned and
different career paths and how
that influences you and the
role that you have now too.
What was that moment where you
fell in love with statistics? Like, why?
- So that was
when I saw that things were--
even like the
news on TV, they were
talking about data, statistics, data,
statistics. And I'm like,
ha, so statistics is much
more than math. Because
everybody was like, Gabriela,
are you crazy to do statistics?
What are you going to do?
Are you going to be
working in this--
there was one unique, one only
place in Brazil where they
hired statisticians.
It was a governmental
thing and they were like, oh,
are you going to
be working there?
So that was kind
of like, scary.
But once I saw the other side
that people were talking in
the news and the newspapers about
data, statistics, and how
that influenced the decision makers
and all of that.
And I'm like, oh,
there is much more than
what people are telling me
and that it's interesting,
that it's only like the math.
But there is the other piece
about communication and
decision-making
and being a decision-maker
that kind of like shifts
my mindset as well. So that
was the turning point for me.
-
I was just double-checking to see
if there was a question on Slido.
But something that we were
talking about before and I
wanted to make sure we touched
upon it is we were talking about
the process of hiring and
being a hiring manager,
especially when you have a lot
of people reaching out for a role
that I mean, maybe is shared
quite a bit on LinkedIn or role
at Microsoft.
And some things that you've
learned along the way.
And I thought it might be good
for all of us to share some
hiring best practices here too
if we've been on that side,
being the person
interviewing others.
- Yeah, so I had a
few opening roles
a few months ago at Microsoft
to work with AI. So
two, I think, hot things. Like,
working for Microsoft and AI.
Especially because Microsoft
is doing well right now.
So it was a little
chaotic because one,
people would reach
out to me every day
to learn more about the role.
And I think the reason why
also a lot of people were reaching
out to me, not only
because Microsoft and AI,
it's because we went
through massive layoffs
for several months.
So people inside Microsoft
and outside Microsoft,
they were desperate to find
a new job. And of course,
they wanted to be in the
cool thing that it's AI.
So I shared with Rachel and
I shared on LinkedIn that I was
so overwhelmed
by the messages. And I try to
reply to every message. Every
person that messages me,
I try to reply.
And I was like,
I can't scale myself replying.
And I'm not going to do
informational interviews
because I don't think it's fair
for the other candidates.
They all should go
through the same process.
So my response was always like,
please, apply.
The team will review your
resume and then we can talk.
I also build a FAQ,
some questions that people would ask
me. Like for example, those roles,
they are
based here in San Francisco.
So you had to be based here.
And then I explained
the reason why
we were not accepting remote
candidates at this point.
So I took some time to do
this as well. But it was very,
very, very overwhelming
because I couldn't
reply to everybody.
And people would get mad and
send me messages over and over
and over again
trying to push for
some information or to be
on the interview. And it was
very stressful, I would say,
being a hiring manager
in that situation.
It was the first time
that this happened to that scale.
- Yeah,
I'd love to hear other people's
thoughts on this too if you have
tips or feedback or if you want
to just put in the chat too
on how you had dealt
with that before.
It does sound overwhelming,
and you want to be
able to respond to everybody too.
- Yeah because also
I've been on the
other side as well,
and I would be so pissed
when the person don't reply to me.
So I don't want to be that
person. But also like,
how can I not burn out myself
with the amount of
requests? It was insane.
- Yeah.
I see,
there was one other Slido question that
I wanted to get to that was,
do you have any advice for
people who also want to be in
that advocate type role
if they don't necessarily
want to be like an influencer
spamming social media but want
to make good contributions to
the community?
- You don't have to be
that person. You don't have to go--
like,
there are some advocates that
they don't even have social media.
So there are other things that we do.
I'll give an example.
Microsoft, the advocacy in
general, the advocacy role,
we have three pillars.
One, it's content.
So it's writing
content for example.
So you don't have to be
in front of the camera or you
don't have to be
on social media.
The other one is
about community.
It doesn't need to be an
external community but it could
be a community that we
have internally. And the third
pillar, it's around
product feedback.
So it's very different.
So I talked about three
things that people usually don't think
about when they
think about advocacy,
they think that you are going to
be on stage 24/7 talking to people
and going to conferences all
the time, which is not true.
Yes, there is a space for that.
And if you are that person,
you can be that person. But also like,
there are other things that you
can do as well that you don't
have to be an influencer
or you don't have to be
putting your face out there.
- Thank you for that.
I know we have just a few
minutes left here. So something
we always love to ask people
here is if you have any
recommended resources
or books that you
suggest we all check out.
Libby's been doing a great job
keeping track of all of those
book recommendations. So I'd love
to hear what you have.
- I have some--
I can't remember off
the top of my head
some of the--
because I read
a variety of books. Like,
from very kind of like management,
which I also share with
Dipsha. She asked me a few
months ago, I shared some
manager books that I like.
But I read everything from health.
I think the one that I was
reading, I will have to get it.
I started reading
last night, which
it's about--
well, one is Living
Beautifully When
There are
Uncertainty and
Changes. That
one, I finished.
But the one that I'm
reading now is When the
Body Says
No, Understanding
the
Stress-Disease
Connection,
which is very
different from the manager
books that
I read previously.
There was another book,
kind of like cheesy, but
it's a book by Mel Robbins.
And it's something
about the five minutes
something. It's
kind of like a--
how do you call
like a self-help--
how do you call like a help--
- Is it The Five
Second Rule?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Or Five
Minute Rule.
- Something, yeah.
So I listen to
that one. So it's
like, I don't have
one thing that I read,
I read like everything
that I can think of.
But those are some ones.
- I see Adam
said, a Five Second
Rules is a flirt book.
I do think it says
five second rule.
Let me see if this
is the right one.
- No, I think it's five
minutes. Five seconds is too little.
- There's another book
called five seconds then.
Well, those are great
suggestions. Thank you so much.
And I do recommend everybody
check out that link that Libby
shared there because she's
been collecting all the books
everybody has suggested to.
But thank you so
much, Gabriela,
for joining us today and
sharing your experience with us
all. It's been so
fun to have you on.
- Yeah, no, thank
you very much.
I hope we can do this
again anytime soon.
And I'm sorry that I will
miss you all but maybe next year
I'll be there. Yeah, have fun.
- We will really miss you.
I hope if anybody is going
to be at Posit conference
and maybe is thinking,
how do we go and talk
to people or feeling like nervous about
it, please feel free to
reach out to me on LinkedIn.
I would love to meet with
you there, grab coffee,
or just have someone
to walk around with. So
great to see everybody today.
Have a great rest of the day.
- Thank you all for coming
and for the questions.
And feel free to connect.
- Bye, all. Thank you. you.